the midas list is a data-driven ranking
these are the investors who are backing
world-changing companies in the
technology sector
all over the world we take submissions
from dozens of vc firms across
hundreds of partners and we look at
qualifying deals
that meet a couple key criteria they
need to have had an
exit via an acquisition or an ipo over
the past
five years or the company needs to have
raised money
from another investor not the investor
we're looking at
at at least twice the valuation that
investor originally gave it
also within the past five years we look
at companies
that are valued at at least 400 million
dollars by the private market
or 200 million dollars at ipo
or acquisition an interesting thing
about the midas list is we can see
waves of technology companies moving on
to the list
driving investors onto it and they're
often the same companies
that we are using for shopping for
hailing cars getting groceries these
tech companies that we depend on
are also the ones that are getting those
large valuations and market caps and
putting the most investors on the list
the 2021 midas list is an interesting
transition
because we see companies like affirm in
payments
strife coinbase robin hood
doordash airbnb this is the new guard of
companies driving
10 plus investors onto the midas list
they're replacing companies like uber
lyft
twitter those big companies that we
still depend on but if you think about
it they've been around for a few years
now
uber still puts someone like bill gurley
onto the midas list
but airbnb is putting 14 people
onto the midas list and to see that
change of the guard happen in real time
is really fun for me
there was a ton of change on this year's
midas list more than we've seen
in past years we had 23
newcomers that's almost one quarter of
the entire list had never been on the
list before
we also had 10 returnees that includes a
total newcomer in the top 10
michael spicer from sutter hill who is a
key investor
and actually the first ceo of our cover
company
from january snowflake as well
as a returnee in the top ten and
a exciting newcomer woman in the
top half of the list in mara pershinson
she
and her partner pejman nozad were
early investors in doordash with a
relatively small
check but a big one for the size of
their fund that led to
a position with profits in the hundreds
of millions
this year's midas list had 12 women on
it that is tied for a record with 2019
unfortunately this is not the number
that we would necessarily hope to see
moving forward and it reflects
the work that still needs to be done in
the venture capital
industry but some of the women on the
list
do represent a new guard of investors
who we
expect to see on the list for many years
to come
we are really hopeful at forbes to see
the diversity of the list evolve
over time and continue to reflect the
efforts of the industry
it's also a reminder of how far we have
to go
the cool thing about the midas list is
you can see the trends
of technology changing you can see the
waves of new companies that everyone
cares about
uses depends on and so in the pandemic
these companies that we saw popping up
were robin hood coinbase
doordash even airbnb as people were
traveling domestically
and to go work from anywhere and so this
whole new wave of technology companies
was unsurprisingly driving
these investors onto the list so we've
seen the companies in the past year
really take off and that affect the list
and we know that as stripe coinbase and
some of these others like robinhood
go public themselves they'll have an
even bigger impact
in the future
you